[Music]
my review maybe our entries in the oh my
god it's my discord showing this could
be embarrassing the subscribed ringing
2g fuels that's right no I'm not welcome
to the why everyone worry we review the
memes the top-notch memes on this
channel that has been posted this week
let's jump into it okay addiction
hundred eighty B mm I have a feeling
this is gonna be minecraft related how
was my date well it's good now and it's
good now good night gamers in the
beginning you said good morning at the
end you said good night you play [ __ ]
didn't you well I had to build a
redstone contraption listen if I would
want how to prevent play minecraft all
day if I could
sadly I have other responsibilities
sadly I have other things to do but this
is the society we live in
I'm honestly thinking about doing like
one of those marathon live streams where
people just live stream for like 12
hours just so I have an excuse before
I'm like why would anyone do that
minecraft I could play Minecraft for 12
hours then that'd be sick should we do
that no no if this video gets many likes
I might consider it
unknown meatball IKEA recalls meatballs
after detection of horse meat yeah get
Mesa hey what is this an old article
IKEA recalls meatballs oh my yeah this
is 2013 yes to that this was 2013 was
the big story in Sweden because of
course we all love IKEA and of course we
all love our meatballs admit it you
wouldn't eat Jurgen but you would eat
water cow you hypocrite we live in a
society truly day thirteen goodbye Oh No
dear diary what a crazy day Felix and I
spent the morning together he made me a
fancy trampoline and we had so much fun
after that Felix removed the bars of my
cozy metal home
I thought it was going to take me to an
adventure just likes men and yoga to
always talk about instead he made me a
fancy new home it even had a cozy magma
block I am so grateful to Felix for all
that he's done to be unfortunately
accident happened I touched the magma
block too many times and now I'm gone I
know it isn't Felix fault I hope he
knows I loved him
I built a meatball for you what does she
the whole series is now just my
Redemption arc for water sheep trailer
movie oh come on I mean it's pretty
accurate isn't it gonna prank water
sheep when he gets home day 1 day 2 day
817 what if I stopped playing Minecraft
and surrender we'll just wait for me to
come home forever Elon Musk why did you
kill water sheep what the Frick I'm Lily
crying I'm sorry
Elon I'm sorry thank you Peter I had
surgery today and the only thing I look
forward to was watching your Minecraft
video uh-huh
thank you for doing the thing you do and
being the only one that put a smile on
my face today please meet the arrogant
both cow and spin not yet I do fantastic
don't worry I took care of him hope you
have a speedy recovery
I look forward to the Minecraft episodes
just as much okay year 2064 nobody's
watching YouTube anymore Felix mayhem
Rafi hey guys let me tell you I beams
this used to be a joke when I did horror
games I would play horror games when I'm
like 80 and I'll die from like a jump
scare or something
ooh 240p someone's stealing my quality
I'm not sure if this has been on here
all right but I feel like you need to
see this what are you doing in my house
oh my god
where can I get this mod I need this man
come on I need to start downloading
minecraft mods that would be amazing
oh my god another one made a research
pack that gives team wolves colorable or
more that's so badass I need to download
all of this
wait there's a dye work oh my god that's
so awesome we could create the Power
Rangers but with Sven's
friends Rangers doesn't sound as cool
whatever
PD PI torches Ward sheep PETA and walks
interesting ok guys I got to show you
this I think they're onto us
I got a notification this morning they
liked one of my tweets they know what I
did
Pete dice after me guys please help me a
big goddamn it Fame power and a fat bank
account will change almost anyone listen
I understand that I what I did was wrong
what do I got to do a 40-minute apology
video with receipts if that's what it
takes I'll do it god damn it I got an
add-on pute sliced my craft video about
some mobile game which used Felix and my
DCI just wondering if yeah I've seen
this we're contacting to get it shut
down it's annoying thanks for letting me
know huge camera quality prepare for
trouble James Charles microphone no make
it the ultimate crossover I may be a
tummy-tum-tum but I am NOT a dummy damn
he's speaking the language ha ha ha -
yeah all the whole squad oh hey guys
something to smile about
Jurgen is now if he's alive and well in
X and E's you can tell Jurgen is also
alive and well on t-shirts check out an
epic merch very nice link in description
limited time Jergens bergen Watership is
Felix the woodland map you found its use
for locating it will I mention the place
is very dangerous and contains a
magician collie Volkers yeah do not
bring spending your get into that place
they drop the totem I'm dying oh the
baby which when held
can save your life what and regeneration
other buff baby can save life is this
isn't this the part of the
Kojima film he stole it for Minecraft
you get some buffs to okay if anything I
wish you guys told me how freaking long
away they are
I walked 20,000 steps in Minecraft
literally anyone who plays my gripe what
the heck hist
we got a continue sky block I was
laughing so hard at all the memes from
my cobblestone generator
they built a statue of themselves this
is so dumb
hey a Dave oh my god that is so cute
they have you out of gas
oh that's amazing Nate Erik's incredible
job okay we have this squabble son okay
we have this cobblestone generator okay
we have this composter on January with
redstone okay and then the ultimate
cobblestone generator admit that you
were impressed top ten things scientists
typically Stan it worked okay it worked
we're the Big Brain team you guys
wouldn't possibly understand
pity prize home base with the shaders
what what the ham that looks sexy little
doghouse for spend damn the pool of the
water all the IRA golems that ran away
don't you think that will be a little
much like I can't tell damn I can't
believe you guys actually rebuilt the
entire place wait so does it say how to
install it how do I show light little
animation I made a sound that's so cute
guys we have to spend merch as well okay
sister Pfister James Charles playing
Hunger Games
Felix dying in the first five seconds on
a Sunday me and Jack Black are gonna
play Hunger Games and some other
minigames for charity so check that out
on V live TV sighs PewDiePie creeper
that blue eye in the back shed yes so
amazing and I love that song so much
maybe creepers aren't bad after all guys
instead of ending the series with Sven
dives go John wick style and kill
hahaha yes God you know something will
have to be done
Swedish diver finds over 15 doors
underwater much done what the Frick is
am i creating an alternate universe in
Minecraft what is happening here why
does this keep happening is this real
does anyone realize that the time stamp
that Jurgen one dies in part 5 is 732
it's the same with water sheep well
there's too many patterns here I don't
like it I'm getting uncomfortable the
Pew Deepak update okay so this is
another mod custom music disk they have
big lasagne and crocodile Asians what
zombies gets men merged logo on the back
of the Y okay
that's got a cool spawn eggs replaced
with bucket of mob what does that mean
oh I see okay customized def screen with
new def messages yes okay I'm
downloading this this is epic oh my god
I saw this so cute it went Sven ride the
roller coaster very nice thank you
man this is so fun what the Frick yar
again what is happening what this is I
can't tell if you guys are playing my
game or if I'm no you're playing my get
out of my game gamers
what what yeah get money it's a bar oh
my god so you guys have told me that
there's a thing called seed in Minecraft
so if you types life seed in minecraft
it shows a code and that code anyone
else can input and they can join the
same world as you I will share the seed
but I'll do it after we beat the ender
dragon if that's alright okay cuz I'm
worried that if I do then some people
will point out too many things to me and
I just want to have like a normal
experience just letting you know so the
prophecy is true I snuck into area 51 in
Minecraft raiding my back there's so
many similarities the universe's are
colliding this stay truly the end of
time and the Minecraft series is were
predicted it Felix
so good here you go love you also
feelings
get down Jesus frickin crisis dog get
away from him spend that dirty sheep I
want to help spend get off the melons he
crazy
it's pirate time don't go in the bonus
with oh I'm sorry I'll do better
water sheep trap ideas oh my god yes No
someone did it why is he not dead whoa
whoa okay
oh-ho I want to do this that's hilarious
oh my god what is this he falls whenever
he's close oh my god it's like that
ancient Greek myth yes it shoots eggs oh
my god if you guys think I'm bad eye
gamers it's building time let's get it
philic deserved everything that happened
to him at the water temple eyes payment
for what he did to Walter sheep you know
what fine fine
he pies in minecraft let's play episode
50 be like no no one more will die if
feuds get Sven a girlfriend and a Frick
they will have a Sven jr. and that wave
Sven ever dies he will live on through
his son oh my god Sven needs to Frick
right now nobody mom when she walks into
your room oh if this is so nasty oh my
god have you live here what the cow why
aren't you in the water
I made this oh wow it's so great I was
so proud of that building come on Jack
wait I have legs what the Freak yeah
that's very good if Sven dies the series
died automatically boat cow dinner bone
water sheep
arrogance when oh my only friend
water sheep is not dead okay so part
three in part 3 we can see water sheep
stuck in the water like usual but in
part four is not there yes escaped and
has gone somewhere else in part 5
another gray sheep is there but not
water sheep what if he was still alive
and on the run he was never killed his
cologne was my god well well well aren't
you guys detectives huh so you figured
me out I'll find you one day what I
never make my channel about being
Swedish
what I'm a hypocrite Wow oh my god you
is this Hey next one no thank means on
my family-friendly minecraft
how you doing Jurgen skeleton horse
turns to Felix nine-year-olds well there
it is the truth has been revealed gamers
Jurgen has returned no that is not how
it works
Peter pie torturing motor sheep beat if
I accidentally killing father I think I
literally had that expression like I
wonder if anyone will post it I don't
know if I shown this but it's so good
matter Oh toto a very epic oh my god
here it is oh no if Peters don't play
Minecraft anymore
Suren will always be waiting for people
no no I will play forever
Sven and what the Sheep spending their
last moments together F's in the chat
boys so then has no clue at all -
how's your day been it's my friend what
to keep okay yeah I made spend out of
sheep as a reminder for Felix to make of
water sheep my world I did it okay I did
it I'm sorry that's pretty cool actually
I love water sheep and everyone is
confused don't question me and what the
Sheep relationship is very complex and
not everyone can understand all the nine
year olds at the hundred million brofist
yes
have we forgotten about this come on
Minecrafters subscribe gosh darn it then
gets hurt
Felix Hayden I know about the tail thing
everyone keeps telling me you can look
at this how far based on the angle of
the tail if it's up its high if it's low
its low it's very helpful thank you baby
you can come sleep with me tonight
you're nothing oh my gosh
you guys need to drop it alright I'm
actually starting to feel bad people
have gained too much eventually mix up
their games with reality
Felix OH
[Music]
your crush her father her brother her
aches
you okay all right sure a great movie
the crappy sequel the weird spin up the
controversial free oh my god
tour is in California oh cool a wildfire
that's awesome
no there's nothing cool about wildfires
okay guys I made it three weeks without
controversies okay guys minecraft is
doing good okay petition to PewDiePie to
make a little pond for Virgin turtle and
his boyfriend and child okay sorry I
will do that Wow truly cultural men the
only way the only way to enjoy hey there
minecraft with the boys imagine if I was
hired at Mojang minecraft pocket update
everything goes in buckets budgets I saw
this I love it so much thank you
spend an absolute badass survivor five
creeper explosions survive drowning tank
two Trident climbed IKEA Tower
freaked right in front of him to water
she Puetz oh no what the Sheep I miss
him so much
Berenice watching literally anything
else watching a Swedish man walking for
hours while talking to his imaginary dog
when you see yeah yes dinnerbone is near
X 2 5 7 9 5 ok cool
ok this fan art is absolutely incredible
two great games combined that is so cool
thank you guys so much for all the
support and all the memes and all the
good times I I love sharing this couple
of weeks with you in Minecraft it's been
epic check out merch if you want no no
pressure but like do buy it and as
always goodbye
what you never play too bad I'm Elena
Tuvia padded bras peel bar okay you're
you're a deal
louder near the new ocean can you say
every two kirim but then ignored this
O'Dare brought bread
[Music]